only comedians get asked to uh
be in these predicaments that are just
unbelievable but they give us great
stories don't they
oh yeah i mean i remember opening for uh
my buddy uh
a common kurt metzger right uh very uh
a long time ago in new york and that was
it was a part of a house party for like
new year's eve
when we drove out there and it's just
like in a ladies it's in this dude's
or their living room and their kids are
just running by you
say like hey we're doing a proper show
like everybody thinks comedy is gonna
fit everywhere
like they think yeah just get a comedian
and you're like in half the time you're
like this is not gonna go good
and so you go up and i mean i just i
mean
you don't even know i'm doing comedy if
you walked in the party it would take
you a minute to realize the show is even
happening
and then i'm just and the kirk goes up
and he just starts and he does good
because he just starts trashing them
that's what they wanted you know like
half times they just want you to come in
and roast them or something i got asked
once i got i was already on tv i was
already in a show called saying
elsewhere and i got a call
through the comedy store and they said
would you do a house party and i said i
really don't want to do a house party
and then they called me
back about a half hour later and they
said there's got to be a price that
you would do a house party for and i
said yeah
there is a price and i gave them this
crazy figure
they called me back half hour later they
said okay i said really
and then i got scared so i said well
it's got to be all cash now before i go
and they call me back half hour later
and they go somebody just dropped off
the cash
so i go over there and i go okay and
then it was like
saturday night up in benedict canyon and
we in
here in la you know we have all these
winding little canyons that go up into
the dark
and i said to my wife i'm doing a house
party do you want to go she goes no
so i drove up myself and as i'm driving
i'm getting scared like this is some
[ __ ] i'm going to get kidnapped this
is weird
and when i got up in into the dark up
into the canyon there was a
a scantily clad woman waving me down
like it looked like somebody who was a
victim of something like somebody had
taken part of her clothing away
and she said are you howie mandel and i
go yeah she goes okay here's the party
i'll take your car
go through the hedges they don't know
you're here you're a surprise
so i get out of the car it's already
weird i climbed through these hedges
and you could hear maybe 15 people like
not a big crowd but
15 people having a party in the house
some other girl scantily clad girl
leads me into a bathroom and i'm
standing and they go you
be here until somebody goes ladies and
gentlemen howie mandel and i'm standing
there and at this time
in my career i used a lot of props so
i'm taking out my props and my
little toys and i'm standing in the
toilet and i hear in the other and then
finally i hear ladies and gentlemen
howie mandel
and i walk through the door and there's
10 people in this house
maybe six guys and four women
nobody has a stitch of clothing on they
are sucking
and [ __ ] and they're in weird
positions and everything and i i just
look and i thought
this i'm being pranked and i look and
some guy who's being blown is going go
go start
start start and i go start he goes your
act
so now i go hey everybody and i'm i'm
standing there well everybody is
sucking and [ __ ] and there's fluid
being sprayed everywhere
and i do like 15 minutes and i go good
night i go back to the bathroom and i
leave
and it was this guy's bachelor party
here's here's what happened a week later
i'm walking in a mall
and some lady comes up to me and goes
are you howie mandel he said yeah and he
and uh she goes oh my husband says you
performed at so-and-so's bachelor party
last night that you were
last week you were the entertainment and
i looked behind her and about a hundred
yards behind her he's going don't say
anything
don't say anything and i was just hired
so that these people can go back and
tell their wives when they go what was
the show oh we had howie mandel
you know and i was just a cover-up i'm a
cover
but that was like the weirdest show
i got a couple of standing ovations but
not from people yeah
yeah yeah that's like a show that you
want to go you're like well just tell me
that and let me take the money and don't
make me go
like yeah i'll go along right i'll show
you and shut you know like just give me
a heads up
no no pun intended
you